الرئيس الأوكراني يعلن عقاب
كل من يقف إلى جانب روسيا ويتوعد ويهدد،
فهل هو أهل لتهديده؟
روسيا تقول: الغرب يريد استفزازنا
لاقتحام المدن ولكن المدن
ستستسلم بالحصار.
الضربات تتواصل على المدن الأوكرانية
والحصار يكتمل شيئاً فشيئاً،
وزيلينسكي يواصل طلب المعونات لدولته
والعقوبات على روسيا، وإلى متى يا فولوديمير؟
إيران حليف روسيا الذي يطفو على السطح
في استفزاز صريح للولايات المتحدة الأمريكية.
بوريس جونسون: أخطأنا بالاعتماد
على الغاز الروسي.
إذن ما الذي أجبرك يا سيد بوريس؟
أمريكا تحاول أن ترد اتهامات موسكو
باتهامات أخرى لتلهي العالم عما صنعته في أوكرانيا،
فهل تمتلك الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
دليلاً على اتهاماتها؟
تبعات الحرب تصل إلى الدول العربية
واحدة تلو أخرى.. وماذا بعد يا ترى؟
الصين أقرب الحلفاء لروسيا فهل تتحرك قريباً
للوقوف إلى جانب حليفتها؟
الرئيس الأوكراني:
سيُعاقب كل من يدعم القوات الروسية
في حربها على أوكرانيا.. لكن
هل استطاعت أوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها أولاً
حتى تستطيع إرسال التهديدات يمنة ويسرة؟
إنه لأمر محير..!!
زيلينسكي:  هناك خسائر فادحة لروسيا
وهي تبحث عن طرق جديدة لتعزيز قواتها.
لكن بعد ذلك خرج زيلينسكي وقال
يجب إيقاف العدوان الروسي على أراضينا..
والدول الأوروبية مستهدفة من موسكو.
وأضاف: نحتاج المزيد من الدعم العسكري،
وينبغي زيادة الدعم المقدم لنا من أجل حماية شعبنا،
وكذلك أمن وسلامة أوروبا.
ولم يكتفِ زيلينسكي بذلك، وأشار إلى أنه
ينبغي فصل البنوك الروسية تماماً
عن نظام سويفت المالي، والتوقف عن المعاملات
التجارية مع موسكو، موضحاً أن هناك دولاً
وشراكات تواصل معاملاتها التجارية مع روسيا
رغم ما يتعرض له الأوكرانيون.
(روسيا وإيران)
في اجتماع مع نظيره الإيراني أعلن وزير الخارجية
الروسي "سيرغي لافروف" أن روسيا وإيران
تعملان على إعداد وثائق جديدة من شأنها
أن تؤكد الجودة العالية للشراكة بين البلدين.
وقال "لافروف" إن روسيا تقدر موقف إيران
الموضوعي بشأن أحداث أوكرانيا.
وأشار إلى أنه ينوي أن يبحث مع نظيره الإيراني
مواصلة تنسيق الإجراءات بشأن التسوية السورية
والأزمات الأخرى في الشرق الأوسط،
إضافة إلى الوضع في أفغانستان.
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجية الإيراني
عبداللهيان: اليوم من المهم للغاية إجراء محادثات
حول الأحداث في أوكرانيا وأفغانستان واليمن وسوريا،
فضلا عن قضايا أخرى في الساحة الدولية.
وأضاف: بغض النظر عما يحدث في الساحة الدولية،
فإن تطوير العلاقات مع جارتنا روسيا
يحظى بأهمية بالنسبة لجمهورية إيران الإسلامية.
عمدة ماريوبول: 2100 شخص من المواطنين
قُتلوا منذ بدء الحرب الروسية ضد أوكرانيا..
وروسيا تنفي استهداف المدنيين
(روسيا والصين)
تعتبر الصين في المرتبة الثانية كمستورد
من روسيا، وعُقدت بينهما عشرات الصفقات
العسكرية في الفترة الماضية.
ومنها:
مقاتلات سوخوي 27 الاعتراضية..
وحصلت الصين على ترخيص يمكنها
بموجبه إنتاج 200 طائرة من هذا الطراز.
ن
قل التكنولوجيا العسكرية الحساسة..
إقامة مناورات برية وبحرية وجوية بشكل سنوي.
(الأحداث والتطورات)
تحدثت مبعوثة الشؤون السياسية للأمم المتحدة
"روزماري ديكارلو" عن تقارير مؤكدة
عن استخدام القوات الروسية للذخائر العنقودية،
في المناطق المأهولة بالسكان.
هذه التصريحات يبدو أنها رد على اتهام موسكو
بأن هناك مختبرات لأسلحة بيولوجية
بإدارة أمريكية في أوكرانيا،
ليستمر الجانبان بتبادل الاتهامات..
لكن روسيا تقول بامتلاك وثائق
بينما لم تفصح أمريكا عن أدلتها..
ديكارلو: حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا
ضربت أساس الهيكل الأمني الأوروبي...
قال المتحدث باسم الرئاسة الروسية "الكرملين"
ديمترى بيسكوف اليوم إن وزارة الدفاع الروسية
لا تستبعد السيطرة الكاملة على المدن الأوكرانية
الكبرى ذات التعداد السكاني الكبير.
وقال إن الدول الغربية تحاول استفزاز
روسيا لكي تقتحم هذه المدن بحسب ما قال.
وسائل إعلام أوكرانية تنشر صوراً
لاستهداف الجيش الروسي لمصنع
"أنتونوف" للطائرات العملاقة في كييف..
الأمم المتحدة: روسيا تستخدم ذخائر عنقودية
في المناطق المأهولة.
صور لمروحيات كا 52،
الروسية تستهدف عدداً من الآليات العسكرية الأوكرانية..
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
"بوريس جونسون" إن الغرب ارتكب خطأ فادحاً،
حيث واصل الاعتماد على النفط والغاز الروسي
عقب ضم موسكو شبه جزيرة القرم عام 2014.
وتابع قائلاً:
طالما أن الغرب يعتمد اقتصادياً على بوتين،
فإنه سيفعل كل ما في وسعه لاستغلال هذا الاعتماد.
وهذا هو السبب في أن هذا الاعتماد
يجب أن ينتهي الآن.
المتحدث باسم الخارجية الأمريكية:
لن نسمح لأي دولة تحاول إنقاذ روسيا من مأزقها الاقتصادي.
أردوغان: نحن ننظر إلى روسيا وأوكرانيا
كدولتين تجمعنا بهما علاقات ثنائية.
أشار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب أردوغان
إلى أن حلف شمال الأطلسي "الناتو"
مؤسسة منظمة مبنية على الدفاع واستخدام
جميع الطاقات، لافتاً إلى أنه في الوقت
الذي نتخذ فيه إجراءات تتعلق بأمن أوروبا،
اتفقنا على تسريع الجهود الدبلوماسية
للتوصل لحل للأزمة الأوكرانية.
القوات الروسية تسيطر على ميناء برديانسك
في بحر آزوف.
بعد العراق ها هي تبعات الحرب الأوكرانية الروسية
تصل إلى لبنان بأزمة قمح،
وتضخم في أسعار الخبز متوقع قريباً.
الجيش الأوكراني يطلق صاروخاً
على إقليم "دونيتسك".
أوكرانيا تختنق وقوافل المساعدات الغربية
تواجه صعوبة في الوصول لأوكرانيا.
السيناتور الأمريكي "غراهام" يعود مجدداً
ليطالب بقتل بوتين.
وقال إن "بوتين" سيقتل برصاصة في رأسه
إذا قرر الحرب النووية.
فكيف سيكون رد الزعيم الروسي على ذلك؟
الملياردير الأمريكي "إيلون ماسك"
يتحدى الرئيس الروسي "فلاديمير بوتين"
في نزال مصارعة والفائز يحصل على أوكرانيا..
تراشق للاتهامات بين موسكو وواشنطن،
ومجاعة تهدد الدول العربية قبل غيرها
والمدن الأوكرانية محاصرة
والدعم الغربي بالأسلحة متواصل،
وبين هذا وذاك يخرج المهرجون ليطلقوا تحدياتهم..
فما هو مصير العالم يا ترى؟